In today's video,
we are going to find out
if you can make slime
out of ballpoint pen ink.
[Music]
Guys, a few of you wanted to see
if we could make slime
out of pen ink.
A few of you.
This is 48 comments,
and the irony of this is
that they were more,
but we ran out of
printer ink to print them.
So I guess,
we're going to try and make
some slime out of pen ink.
But first,
we should probably address
the elephant in the room.
My black gloves
are gone, you guys.
We've decided to wear white
gloves with this video because
if you've seen our previous
videos with the ink,
it stains everything.
We kind of want to see
how bad it's going to be.
Here's the basic idea.
Taking our leftover
ballpoint pen ink,
we are going to mix
that with some regular slime,
and see if we can get
it to hold together.
To start off,
we are going to make the most
basic slime there is, borax,
clear glue, and water.
Let's get mixing.
Start off with 1 cup water,
and 1/2 teaspoon borax.
[Music]
Once your borax is dissolved,
add 1/2 cup of water
to 5 ounces of clear glue,
which is just over 1/2 cup.
[Music]
All right, before I
combine these two,
I'm actually going
to add the pen ink
to our glue mixture.,
see if that's even going to mix
it all before we add the borax.
This might be the very end
of our ink, guys.
We're just going
to start with a little.
When I say a little,
I mean about a
hundred pens worth.
[Music]
Oh, wow.
Right from the start,
you can actually see the blue
is separating right out.
Pigments rising to the top.
Now, you can actually
see the copper
and the blue has sort
of separated here.
Now, it almost looks
like an oil spill.
It doesn't look quite
the same as the surface
of our ink itself,
but you definitely have
that metallic shine.
[Music]
Oh, something happened.
Wait.
[Music]
Awesome.
Guys, I think it worked.
We have pen ink slime.
[Music]
Well, it definitely worked.
You can still see these bits
of copper everywhere.
But the blue,
you can actually see,
it's kind of coming
out on my gloves.
So it's separated.
But to be honest,
it's not making nearly
as huge of a mess
as I thought.
I was expecting this
to stick to everything.
But instead of sticking
to everything, it's just
a beautiful metallic slime.
The color is really
not sticking to my gloves
as bad as I thought it was,
so I'm gonna do something
that's probably not smart.
They have to know.
[Music]
That's not nearly as bad as I
was already expecting.
Yes.
It's getting some ink on me,
but it's not like a full coat.
It's just barely there.
Oh wait, there's our blue.
See that?
When it gets thin
and transparent...
Wow, it's almost like we have
little galaxies forming in it.
It's honestly what
it looks like.
That is so cool.
All right, you guys win.
This is awesome.
I want to see it outside.
Let's see if we can get
it in the sunlight.
It's honestly metalic ooze now.
It looks so coppery red.
[Music]
See how the color moves,
like there's blue up here.
[Music]
Well, a couple of you
said you wanted to see
if it could be frozen.
[Music]
Let's see if we find that again.
I don't think the snow
is going to do much to it.
But again, I'm very surprised,
the color is just
not coming off.
Not even sticking
to it a little bit.
Snow staying very white
no matter where it goes.
So I got more ink on my hands
because I was trying
to mix it with my fingers,
instead of just
letting it solidify.
But it's holding together.
Alright, so I'm back inside,
and we've actually
made a second batch
of ink slime for a little bit
of a different contrast.
This one, we've used
a lot more pigment.
So this one,
you can actually see
right off the bat.
There are these copper swirls
in my first batch.
Now on my second batch,
I use probably
double the amount of ink,
and it is just
an inky black in comparison.
It's also interesting to note
that this one is also
a lot more malleable.
My first one,
very very firm, wants to rip.
I think I pulled it
out of the borax solution
a little too quick.
But this one is much goopier,
and I've noticed
there is a difference
when hold them up
into the light.
You get a lot more copper coming
through on this one,
but our second batch...
Now the first colors
to come through this one,
blue and almost a deep green.
All of these are just starting
to look like nebulas to me.
This is awesome.
Now, obviously, my hands
are stained to death
because I've mixed
two batches now of this stuff,
but I want to see
if it actually
will stay in paper now
that it's fully mixed.
So our first batch,
which is what more brittle.
Just leave that there.
The second batch.
Now, if I just rub
these along the paper.
Well...
It's brittle, but it's
just dusting away.
There's really not
any staining happening.
This more oozy second batch.
That's about the same,
but the color itself
isn't actually really
sticking to the paper.
The ink is well
and truly in the slime.
This is in fact
ink pigmented slime,
and I cannot get over
these little galaxies in here.
All right.
Well, we've made two different
types of slime with our pen ink,
but this comment suggest
that we also make ink oobleck.
Let's try it.
All right, for the oobleck,
as much fun as it would be to
just simply dump the cornstarch
in the rest of our pen ink,
I don't want to
destroy it all yet.
So I'm going to put
some in with water,
and then try and mix
in the cornstarch,
and see what that looks like.
Right away, it
disperses so much faster
than it did in just
the glue and water.
[Music]
The coloring just reminds me
a lot of the blue glaucus.
It's this little tiny sea slug,
but that coloring is identical.
Just mix it straight
into the water.
Oh, well, immediately,
it's almost dried
on the surface.
It cracked right through.
That's weird.
It actually doesn't really
want to mix in with the water.
All right, we're going
to try this a different way.
We're going to pour
the water out,
and I'm going to add cornstarch
just to the ink itself,
and add water as we go.
Because that's not going
to mix like this.
Ink with just the tiniest bit
of water still in the bowl,
which is really cool
because as I stir it,
you can watch the blue
just sort of seep out.
Now, my concern with this is
that cornstarch is very opaque,
and I am not sure
what that's going to do
to our coloring here.
Because right now,
you can see it's mixing
into the water,
but it's really not wanting
to have anything to do with ink,
which is actually making
for a pretty cool result.
All right.
Let's add a touch more water,
see if it'll actually mix now
that cornstarch is involved.
[Music]
Got the gloves back on
so let's try this out.
[Music]
It feels exactly
like regular oobleck.
The difference is this
will never come off.
[Music]
Side-by-side comparison.
This popsicle stick
only has ink,
and this one has oobleck.
If you look
at the difference here,
I mean the differences
in viscosity is apparent,
but color-wise,
they're even closer
than the ink slime is.
Let's take a look at that.
Now, the ink slime you can see
that the pigment
is actually still separated.
You've got touches of blue
in our darker pigmentation,
and the copper is really showing
through in our first batch.
Then our oobleck
and our straight pen ink.
Much closer.
I don't think there's
any saving this Oobleck.
Now, I didn't want
to make too much
because I didn't want
to use all of the pen ink.
See how it just reacts
just sit in for a second.
Normal Oobleck will just pool
and almost form like a liquid.
So, let's see if it does that.
Well, what we may have done
is just dried out the ink,
which actually makes sense.
Sometimes, if you're
using an ink pen,
you can actually dust the paper
when you're done
to try and dry it faster.
I'm almost wondering
if that's what we've done here
with the cornstarch.
It's absorbed so much
of the liquid in the pen ink
that it's almost lost
its fluid nature.
It's still there,
but it's definitely not as
a liquid as regular Oobleck
anymore, even as liquid as it
was 10 minutes ago.
But it's sure making
some cool patterns.
The messiest way to paint.
Well guys, can you
make ink slime?
Yes, you can.
Can you make ink Oobleck?
Yes, you can, and it's awesome.
We still have a little bit
of pen ink left.
So if there's anything else
that you want to see us do with that,
let us know
in the comments below.
Guys, that was awesome.
Thank you for your suggestions.
But you know we've always
got more for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video,
and that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle
to subscribe to the club
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bellm
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.